VINCENT VANHOUCKE:
So you've heard
of deep learning, one of
the hottest areas in machine
learning today.
Wondering what the
buzz is all about?
Problems you want to solve,
but not sure where to start?
Take this Udacity
course on deep learning,
and let's start exploring.
Through hands-on
assignments, you
will learn how to build
progressively more
complex models using Google's
open source TensorFlow library.
Learn all about
deep nets, ConvNets,
embeddings, and
LSTMs, and use them
to solve a variety of problems,
like classifying images
and predicting
sequences of text.
So what are you waiting for?
Enroll in this
course and see what
deep learning can do for you.